so lots of chat at the moment about
sweden and finland joining nato and i'm
here on the swedish island of gotland
it's a popular tourist destination but
it has another role as well as you can
see troops are here on the island
they're training they're camouflaging
this vehicle and that's because this
island has a really important strategic
location
why you ask well let's have a look at
the map so it's about location so here
you have gotland then you have sweden
estonia latvia lithuania
and importantly here kaliningrad which
is an enclave of the russians so they
say if you control this island then you
can control the air and the sea in the
southern baltics
and already the swedish forces here have
had to respond since uh the uh war in
ukraine so in february the russians
brought more navy reinforcements to
kaliningrad so as a response the swedish
boosted troops here just to show them
that they had that capability and going
forward they hope to boost the number of
troops on this island so that they can
respond to any threats and speaking to
some of the soldiers here they're
already ready to do their bit for nato